[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Cup head now Cup head is
a game that came out about two months
ago
hi guys yes it is Sam and if you know me
you know that I'm incredibly skilled and
talented at playing games and if you
could stop laughing for one moment you
would know that I'm telling the truth
when it comes to shoot-'em-ups or shmups
I'm actually pretty good at them that
wasn't too evident in topper that I just
did but that is a thing so hey how's it
going guys so cup had um I was uh I've
never played it before obviously but
I've also I haven't seen much gameplay
of it but I know it's supposed to be
difficult now that doesn't mean bad
things but it means that an aramis I
make excuse nama flips once upon a time
in a magical place called inkwell aisle
there were two brothers named cup peg
and mug Minh Cup head and mug man
they lived without a care under the
watchful eye of the wise elder kettle
okay one day the two boys wandered far
from home and despite the elder kettles
many warnings ended up going on the
wrong side of the tracks and ended the
devil's casino inside Cup head and mug
man soon found themselves on a winning
Street at the craps table hot dog
explained king dice the casinos sleazy
manager these fellas can't lose
nice run boys laugh the UH new comer the
brothers gasp it was the casinos owner
the devil himself now how about we raise
the stakes he suggested with the toothy
grin when Manoir roll and all the loot
in my casino is yours the devil boomed
but if you lose I'll have your souls
deal cuphead blinded by easy riches
nodded and grabbed the dice for a throw
good gosh cuphead no fried mug man for
he understood the danger but it was too
late Snake Eyes laughs the devil while
slamming the floor you lose the brothers
trembled in fear as he loomed over them
now about those schools
Oh the brothers pleaded for their very
lives there must be another way to repay
you mug man stammered yes please mister
cut man added hmmm perhaps there is the
devil snickered pulling out a parchment
I have here a list of my runaway debtors
collect their souls for me and I might
just pardon you two mugs now get going
the devil roared kicking the boys out
most rudely you have till midnight
tomorrow to collect every one of those
souls otherwise I'll be the one
collecting yours combat mug man were
terribly frightened and ran away as fast
as they could
come on Bhagat panted cuphead we have to
find the elder kettle he'll know what to
do I don't know if you will know what to
do
alright anyway I'm gonna yeah so this is
uh yeah I don't know I don't know how
he's gonna go
what a fine pickle you boys has gotten
yourselves into alright okay I know you
don't want to be pawns of the devil but
if you refuse I can't bear to imagine
your fates I must play along for now
connect those contracts and you'd best
be ready for some nasty business
your daddy's friends won't be very
friendly once you confront them in fact
I expect they'll transform into terrible
beasts take these potions so they won't
hang you out to dry we'll give you the
most remarkable romantical abilities now
go to riding desk and use the mystical
inkwell there you need to prepare
yourself for a scrap alright okay
alright
tutorial I should probably do this I
have no idea how to play duck hold down
to crouch alright got it
hey short jump hold for a high jump oh
why - twice why - what does B do I can't
be B - right
hey descend from certain platforms
all right right mouse button to stay
locked in place
oh that's handy wait ah oh oh when I'm
staying in place
ah okay Perry slap but is that my
handers at hand coming out of my bop
boom Bop
oh oh okay I see oh oh well I don't have
a two-player so I guess I'm by myself
now
all right well alright yeah I'm gonna I
think I can change the controls I'm
gonna make just in case let's see
keyboard controller what does this be do
anything Axew
what does ax shoot mean I feel like beef
should be - if X shoot is something
fancy then I'm gonna change that replace
with what Oh replace okay I'm gonna
change this up I don't know what that
was all about but okay alright X move
y-yeah see if I gotta do something quick
I imagine I may be dashing a lot so why
wouldn't that change that to be alright
okay I got this I got this guys I got
this okay alright I got this
alright now I'm not promising I'm gonna
be Reggie but you know you guys know how
I am with rage games so we're just gonna
see how this goes
deliver - buh buh buh buh buh bluelab a
boom boom boom okay alright okay alright
well grandpa I'm off to lose my soul
I'll have to lay out all those debtors
to move on now shake a leg get to
murdering alright grandpa I'll do you
proud don't you worry about a thing
this is gonna be great it's gonna be
some special I know that there's gonna
be something it's gonna be a whole lot
of some oh hi those are gone hey fellas
looks like you're in for it now eh well
I used to be the same way always getting
in trouble
runnin jumpin shootin but now I prefer
just strolling around and going to the
pictures hey let me give you a hand
take this Wow three Co coins thank you
thank you for that
what can I get for that pork rinds
Emporium oh boy
pork rind he thinks you might find that
name offensive chaser X chaos orbit
long-range with below average damage no
aiming required extra hit point spread a
way shoot rain with great damage if you
can keep close to your target okay
[Music]
jumbo rebound great coverage with
average damage in backwards for maximum
range I don't know what the hell that he
was even talking about I'm gonna go with
the chaser I like me a chaser alright
lobber Tex
kablooie medium range and good damage
with it okay you know what all right
goodbye pork rind goodbye alright
you gots to equip those new purchases if
you wants to use them look at your equip
card you bums alright okay whoa list Oh
whew that's a lot of schools beep okay
got that I guess super no super charm no
charm okay alrighty then what's this
then the root pack in botanic panic
difficulty simple or regular go simple
on you guys I'm about to go regular on
you guys and you gotta see all the skill
that I got
Oh oh hi wallop whoa whoa wait whoa whoa
hey hey whoa what are you doing what are
you doing
switch oh no aiming required I like this
oh this is nice
oh this is lovely well so far so oh whoa
whoa wait whoa whoa
why isn't shoot like right right bumper
or something like that
I feel like shoot should be like left
bumper is that way I can't III live it
wait hey I'm a change that again hang on
and you need to change everything okay
all right
right bumper is okay ex shoot his switch
weapon okay that's good so I'm gonna
make shoot left trigger yeah okay and
then that's good right maybe maybe
excuse should be right trigger then no
okay let's try this
ah that's much better oh look at this is
much better
Oh is he dead oh ho oh oh hey oh hey
onion how's it going
sorry burn oh my me oh oh I can't move
to you oh I see how it is
okay all right hang on nyeeehhh are you
all right god damn I'm a pro god damn
I'm so good at this game
goddamn look how good I am okay all
right can you stop crying you big bubble
blowing baby I mean I get that you're an
onion and crying is kind of the thing
you caused but it doesn't have to be the
thing you do well
[Music]
all right well that's a thing hey that
don't look good a good thing I got home
and good man this this gun makes it easy
oh that don't look at that
Oh carrots are good for your eyes oh I
get it
good for your vision now it's real funny
I was funny like it's so funny it's
almost no skill involved with this one
okay well there's some skill involved
when I run right into that OOP
eyes way better way better cuz way
better flaps blab say nothing cuz it's
supposed to be hard
ha ha I bet this game doesn't get any
harder than this alright he's sad well
his souls gone it's all right okay well
there we go got that oh yeah you guys
are right the pink ones - yeah that's
why also I changed it so that I could a
better parry that's totally that's
that's a hundred percent what I meant to
do yes okay
all right got it God okay I got it Oh
Oh whole contract the root pack you got
the root pack soul contract now why
didn't it well these people keep giving
their souls to the devil it seems like a
a not good thing Forest Follies
run-and-gun okay all right
whoa what am i running in one of my
Gunung oh I'm running okay all right
well this is running and this is gunning
definitely all these people
unfortunately are dying
can I parry that but okay I don't know
if I can parry that oh I wanted to try
though
I can definitely parry that one oh boy
okay come on nope not okay hang on I'll
get them go get the parry I'll get the
parry just complicated matter your ah
can I bury that oh it's scary it's a
scary parry okay I got it
apparently I'm not all good it did me
but I'm scary parried it I'm scared game
in so bad it's game in so bad
boink well that's that I parried that
there we go okay I'd be very careful
about the Paris bears into bears little
perilous okay I know what I'm doing oh I
died damn it
well that's okay cuz I'm getting the
hang of it the first step don't mean
nothing okay maybe I should switch way
up and down look at this that's such a
good Gundam why would I do the normal
gun when I got this gun I mean I know
it's probably weaker but more shots are
gonna hit so it kind of all evens out
huh no aiming required whose magical
magical world of the living
got ya
I don't need to parry these things but
I'm gonna lap very requires so much oh
but it just does everybody hold on so
cute and adorable when they died oh no
no no no there we go
is it crazy I'm crazy ah easy saying the
world nope oh okay oh boy that was weird
alright hey how are you supposed to
avoid that then oh jeez I'm sorry yeah
it's be one good Oh a corn maker oh
that's that's problem that's a problem
you mean bomb maker you mean bomb maker
is what you mean okay there we go hey
stop that now okay I can see where this
game might get difficult for some
scrublords ain't too good at games not
not me though pretty good at games you
know that guys they didn't know that but
nobody knew that I was right there I was
right there ah surprise on me I was
who'da thunk I was right there
ah damn it okay alright well I got this
guys I got this man wait for it wait for
it for the skills on its way this is why
I did this live so you couldn't see that
I wasn't goofing yeah like all my skill
is readily apparent Josh McElveen bat oh
I meant to smack for pakil you but got
it
and he ever report an important race of
who smack that pink bastard
I'm the winner oh I love the sound
effects in this by the way now I mean
number one like this style is super
charming am I supposed to I supposed to
actually be able to make this jump that
that's something that's
I can't double chop all right okay all
right well all right that's the thing
yeah I can't I can't double jump so what
is it wasn't it expecting me to do huh
what's it expecting huh there's some
mechanic I'm missing here there's some
some goofy goofy thingamabob er that's
supposed to help me get to my
destination
bab-ee the forest needs to calm the hell
down
[Music]
okay - OH - right I have a - I forgot
about that that's right
oh yeah - the button that I said I need
to change that that's right okay hang on
I'm customizing I got it yeah oh yeah
hang on watch this what she how that's
that what BAM right trigger now I'm a
I'm a frickin pro and then yeah okay
here we go
you seeing this all right wait I gotta
remember what I just changed - right
right uh uh I got it got it got it got
it
the best okay hang on I'm the best I'm
the best guys I'm the best way for it
wait a breath and pull the best I'm the
best you guys all know how good I am at
being the best there ah well well this
is a pretty arias predicament well all
right
right okay okay let's fold on yours is
or if you have horses hold them keep
them closed and love them boy I'm up
[ __ ] creek without a paddle aren't I
okay all right so far so goofy all right
easy ah you like it
Bravo liked it weren't nothing like it
to work nothing like it twerp nothing I
got it
two years later what do you talk about I
don't even know who you are who are you
why are you who sent you here ha ha ha
ha ah yeah that's the good stuff
give me that any - ha ha ha see see how
it go see I told you I'm incredibly
skilled at games and such as the like as
this i am i know i won't inhale your
dong actually I won't do that
hope you didn't know hope you weren't
gonna banking on that all right what's
with you tree huh
why are you shaky news you say all right
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa oh you didn't
tell me you're gonna bounce off the wall
like that it's like frickin don't why
are you doing I don't like that okay all
right you're weird
I don't like weird I like normalcy boy
thank you nope not what I wanted okay
all right well all right then I didn't
expect you to stuff
no I what is that I don't know today I'm
gonna block I'm gonna people back that I
pitbull backed it oh you I'm the wall
thing oh the wall thing oh the wall
thing okay I'm a handsome slime bringing
pain one bounce at a time
all right here we go here we go got you
you got your number huh you think you
don't got my number
you ain't gonna call me after dinner huh
what's going on with you all right no no
no no you ain't punch them thank God
nothing thank God nothing no I think I
think and therefore I'm not em okay how
am I supposed to know any okay all right
yeah you do that you do that oh oh ah I
got two of them that was good yeah
bounce okay
oh that's scary okay oh I thought you're
gonna hit the wall
[Music]
am I supposed to do uh yeah okay well
that hurt a lot okay I got this one I
got this how am I supposed to know how
much healthier uh is there something to
do with oh the cards that's right that's
right the cards are like mine ah I know
it oh um oh I don't know why did i do
what did i do yeah I think oh ha ha
got ya what did that do why did that do
that oh oh boom how about some of this
nah get get like this slap up your butt
oh god I'm so scared
life isn't scariest thing uh oh god I
pushed the wrong button I thought I hit
- ah doc Oh doc yeah no I didn't go
listen to that I forget those a thing
Oh duck that's right duck dip duck dive
dodge duck duck I'm ducky
hahahaha oh [ __ ] I got too caught up in
my ah crap dive right into him alright
hang on I'm still getting used to the
controls guys hang on oh god I keep it
in the wrong button for - huh
[ __ ] I got it guys hang on ah I'm gonna
go through their gun now I'm gonna
wallop okay you ain't a match for Cuffy
Hattie doc nothing I need to oh man okay
all right oh I'm tells me I should
probably use a duck the directional pad
and not necessarily go this thing okay
here we go I got it oh [ __ ] okay all
right okay - that way Hey
ah I'm okay I'm okay whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa laughs you didn't oh god you didn't
tell me but I thought those I was you
know that was my bad okay that was my
bad
all right han wait I guess switch over
to the other the homing gun seems like
good talk wall duck okay I got this guys
everybody hold on to your hats if I hold
on your duck all right I got this
now I know all the tricks in the book
hey yeah directional pad probably way
better yet directional pad is in fact
way better
oh no no wow oh I got hit multiple times
baskets Walt
[Music]
ah no I was too close all right I got
this guy's everybody stop for Bucky hush
your face oh whoa whoa whoa whoa I don't
know how I didn't get hit by that but I
am just so skilled all right oh no not
there
Oh God he fixed me out that's what's
going on oh why am I even trying what
does that do for me
[Music]
I got this I got this I got this
okay I got this
all right easy easy easy easy
fat don't know why I'm doing that but I
did it
[Music]
hey all right yeah and every time I get
better in this game i just happened to
shut up ah no wrong but I see I talk and
everything goes to [ __ ] ah kids it's
it's the lets players conundrum you
can't talk and be good at the same time
all right I'm ready for you wherever
you're going okay I I ain't about this
oh oh oh what you gonna do miss me
dude oh that is quite a bow it's quite
quite a bow Hey okay alright okay
alright
No
[Music]
I got the achievement ceramic strike
whatever that is a boom boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom
[Music]
this games fun as heck oh this games fun
as hack as pack Oh fun fun fun for the
whole family
Oh goopy Legrand ooh soul contract okay
alright well got that Missy surfing's
upload this job I don't know what these
other things new okay I don't want that
spread extra hit point lightly weakens
your attack power hmm great coverage
with average damage and backwards for
maximum range oh ok smoke bomb invisible
- you will not take damage during a - a
great defense that's really handy pee
sugar I don't know fun more your first
berry move is automatic all you need to
do is jump oh yeah okay alright then but
that's good that no not that this charm
ah that's really handy - really handy I
don't have a super I will get it super
eventually I imagine what is this guy
this guy's all about hey buddy what you
doing up here her ups I'll be a monkey's
uncle if I'm putting my moolah in the
bank for all I know the devil probably
controls the place too they'll never get
a hold of my gold if I spread it all
around and if some Joe happens to find a
coin or do good for him
that's what I say harrumph alright thank
you for that I guess alright clip joint
calamity alright okay alright
oh jeez man this is nothing but boss
fights I love that it's so fun Oh what
are you doing I don't like that hey oh
oh oh duck oh god I'm not ready oh I
missed it oh god how am I supposed to
parry solo what are you doing what do
you don't what are you doing do you know
why that why why you don't need to do
that that's not necessary in any
capacity your gums oh I tried that's
tragic Oh got it
no I don't even need the parrot I don't
have a super what am i doing BAM boom
[Music]
okay why are they spitting flies what
kind of oh oh that does look good oh god
that looks bad
I didn't - I didn't - alright learning
the fight learning fight I'm learning it
I'm learning it okay I'm ready hooray oh
jeez gosh oh gosh jeez ah truck really
hard
[Music]
oh my god oh man if you Perry and bounce
like that you got to be on the maneuver
all right I got this I don't know why
why am I getting it Wyatt is seriously
Wyatt there's no reason I don't know I
don't have a super I don't even know how
to use the zubur wait is wait oh wait no
no no wait no this is my it is my super
I I am using the super question mark
these are my supers oh oh oh I don't
like that oh that's no no no this
shouldn't have danced oh hey hey buddy
everybody hey buddy hey oh this is my
super these are my supers aren't they
isn't that am I just how dumb am i
extremely extremely dumb bummed am i
extremely dumb I think I'm extremely
dumb I'm very dumb morning oh that I
don't like that face that face not good
I dashed oh I - I mean I'm invulnerable
when I dance I totally for lunch
oh I'm involved wait oh oh
knocked it okay I don't know what that
did for the devil are they good I mean
I'm invulnerable when I - I forgot I
forgot then I didn't use it right ah
Oh God okay I got it I got it I get it I
get it okay they're not supers okay I'm
not they're not supers I'm not dumb
thankfully we've scientifically proven
that I'm not dumb good I'm glad we
cleared that up
Oh what no I parried that god I need the
parry charm god damn it
[Music]
Wow
oh no oh I don't know how that guy turns
into a fan is my real question here I
mean I'm not wanting to question the
scientific procedures of a cartoon game
but it seems a little odd you're gonna
say it out loud I don't know if it's
rude of me but just seemed a little
weird
nothing I'm the old off that face again
again don't like that face why do you
run into his mouth that just seems like
a weird thing like a strategy in a game
as far as like strategies go that
doesn't seem to be the right one tiger
oh that ain't good okay you can stand on
if I didn't realize you can stand on um
oh I shouldn't - so much I got this I'm
so good at games guys I'm so good guys I
heard how good I am at games
okay all right everybody hold on to your
hats everybody hold on your grip dragon
hats bothering you I just said I wasn't
good about a pairing you've been a
parrot it oh I'm so scared those Goods
games just scare me
I skip so freakin scared man it'd be a
lot easier with two players huh well
whatever oh well there goes that dream
how that parried you I don't know why
Oh laughs laughs lip balm
[Music]
Oh - [ __ ] - to God ah why why mrs.
stupid some stupid stupid uh-huh
alright he's gonna charge into his mouth
and then I'm gonna not be stupid that's
the only answer to this question he
could go in his mouth throwing his mouth
frog brother weird and then I can just
dodge it normally because I don't
actually need to do anything smack all
right why wait do I not even have do I
even have to do that someone tells Matt
whoa
okay alright well this is easy ah okay
ah
easy easy easy the easiest thing in the
world cuz I'm not reading into it too
much oh god yeah Oh dad good blame you
blam blam
[Music]
so scared I'm just so scared in life you
know I'm gonna go with the normal gun
because just shooting for I bet it does
more damage but oh I need it for this
this is good for this but only good for
that otherwise switch guns right that's
the strategy I should employ oh this
better this is good it feels good feels
good okay and then back alright this is
a good stretch good fat gets right -
good good good good shot you good choice
[ __ ] I don't like that
[Music]
laughs that's Oh those quick bat bat bat
bat okay
okay okay go on to him yeah it's doing
way more damage both with what I'm doing
and also the super yeah I got this
are you want time whoops oh whoops died
there Oh scary scary but not that scary
now I don't know what that means I don't
like this no I dodge I die this is okay
it's okay I don't know where I'm going
when I'm invisible hey hey hey oh god
why am i dashing why do I do that to
myself oh go again why not hate myself
hate myself
oh this is easy I got this in the bag in
the bag in the bag in the bag in the bag
in the back in the back in the back in
the bag in the bag and the bag in the
bag and back in the back in the back in
the baggage no I've got a thumb come on
come on come on easy easy easy
easiest thing in the world I guess you
can only damage him one year when he's
open like that Liz oh oh god oh god not
die not die after that not die I know
die oh this game is easy this game is
easy games easy
Jen's easy
yeah God three months okay that's fun
got it in the bag in my bag it's in my
bag
my bag is full of it god this got this
got this got this great I'm great I'm
great I'm great I'm the great stomach
ribs and the greatest guys are the
greatest
from the greats do you know how great I
am great the answer is extremely ribbing
crooks they're dead they're gone they're
dead they're just dead gone forever
completely dead
never see their families again they're
just dead where am I going next
all right okay all right what's up next
hey how's it going you want to be dead
I've been murdering what's that you do
want to fly in a plane like I do you're
not sitting in any cockpit till you
study those blood breads all right okay
we'll find them
aeroplane blueprint why why is this it
[Music]
hold right trigger to shrink this
doesn't make any sense okay
[Laughter]
all right I'm down okay all right whoosh
all right I guess I got this I don't
know what I'm doing but I'm going flying
apparently we're going flying guys guys
we're going flying I did it we are proud
of me got you two mugs are ready for the
wild blue yet there's only one of me all
by myself
just remember those birds are flying
have their own tricks fancy fighting
moves on the ground don't apply up there
though you can feel Perry like the
dickens
be sure to shrink yourself when the need
arises remember when you're short so is
your range see well good luck I suppose
get any of that that doesn't make any
sense sir doesn't make a lick of sense
threatening Zeppelin all right okay oh
hi okay I'm sorry
am i what am i doing to you why am i
doing it also oh no that's not what I
wanted I wanted to Perry not that uh
[ __ ] that was unexpected that was weird
why'd you do that oh I thought I buried
that where are you a ball now I look
away for one second okay whatever you
say Oh shooty keep freaking thing I need
to actually run away from it no whoosh
that's no good okay all right well
that's weird fast
got you we're gonna do about nope that's
a wicked ball that's a weird whoa
I'm moving fast
super but Harry I don't I still don't
know if that's a super or not I'm gonna
bomb you I think that was the correct
maneuver I don't know what happened
I keep transforming into things and I
don't understand I don't get it ah the
two lovers okay all right well then
Roberts gay and come back baby okay so
the super is when you get all the cards
and you save up and then you can blow
them real good
oh boy god damn it not enough one HP
alright I got this I don't like that at
all
what oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god no no no no no no no no no
no no just no aah
No Oh lasers that's what you do
ok I'm so scared I'm so scared I'm so
scared I'm so scared I'm so scared
I am the scariest I am so scared I am
this scared everything have fear fear
nothing but fear inside my soul fear Oh
a slab
[Music]
all right is that the bowl again course
it is fear fear fear fear fear
I slept myself right into that I've got
nothing but fear a slap so good okay Wow
got you that's what you deserve I think
ah where did that come from I haven't
seen that guy before
okay which way you're gonna go smooch
[Music]
slap no there you go that's different
okay
manis boss spices so why is that the way
that that is oh I don't like that I like
that I don't like this guy
oh whoa I don't know if I actually need
to dot anything before that happens
seems like something that's highly
irregular
hahaha I mean she got weaponized
laughter so I I don't know really if I
could question anything okay all right
moon phase coming up problem I was not
paying attention
oh wait no I still being vegetable I
still did all right still the immunity -
yes yeah
don't need to do that I'm gonna do this
now run or skirt oh [ __ ]
oh no if I hit something it does do bad
out no okay all right wait all right -
miss me - oh god no I was paying
attention to the UFO and not the stars
Perry all right god there's so much to
look at oh so it's the look at so let's
look at God God okay all right okay it's
fine
ha ha ha I just got to keep my eyes more
open open to infinite possibilities
infinite possibilities in the horizon
the world is full of possibilities you
need only grasp them it always starts
with the pole laughs nope not today I
was not paying attention
god damn it oh god damn - slap oh here
comes Dumbo me kaboom okay all right
ah no I have doors at doors I'm so bad
ah I'm a blimp you're a wimp I'm not a
wimp I'm not a wimp I swear why do I
need to kill you why can't we get along
you seem like a lovely lady we could be
friends with your hot you you just I
love the way you laugh there's a scrilla
wave what I want to say I can't live
life this way I'm gonna bomb you boom
that's what you get I it was like a life
bar something some life some life in my
life God oh not this [ __ ] slap oh
come on this way okay now it's getting
into like the bullet-dodging I'm fine
with but it's it's when there's ten
bajillion things of God never mind never
mind never mind never mind
guy wasn't panting where did that note
you know I'm gonna retry that one not
gonna do that
okay everybody hold on to your hats I
got this
it's got make do with more dodgy
shrinking what I need
[Music]
okay okay okay okay
Oh where's all my Perry's huh no you
better slap I got incoming yeah how's it
feel Oh how's it feel
yeah yeah like a bag of dicks donut huh
ah your laughter will get you nowhere
sit lap more like my slaps tur god I
hate myself
okay ah the two ladies huh ha ha ha I'm
booming god damn it god damn me and my
good looks slap you Bob
Oh got him oh why is that still there
why is that still exist that's not fair
does he have left and run and run I'm
crazy I'm crazy I'm crazy
she's like a we're moon I guess slap
here we go doubles key Wham
boy that is that is dangerous being in
front of that oh oh man bastards
suck Oh God
[Music]
Oh God I'm so close dad dodge slap - ah
[Applause]
I'm gonna kill know what is that what is
that go away Oh her my eyes have never
been more open
syllabic
[Music]
all right oh my slapper no all right ah
no okay all right slap my missamma slap
hell do I miss okay anyway I go boom
boom the kids boom I miss me miss me
brick you know I'm angry when I switch
into another language accent not another
language it's not even an accent when I
just start talking stupid you know I'm
angry stupidly oh that's not good yeah
yeah we get it we get it whatever it's
arbol probably painful too but I don't
care haha okay all right I don't know
where the UFOs come from dodge Oh
Dodge snapper the ultimate combo here we
go the bomb go down south and in
concoction and a Dodger oh I didn't see
that one that was my game again No
[Music]
now let's get it
I almost got like an A+ if I had to get
hit right at the end there hold it big
dong in me
[Music]
okay all right got this in the bag I'm
so good at everything
ooh still held the burger that's funny
that's funny that's funny
hail de Burgh okay I get it okay you're
funny you're funny I just all right
treat rob trouble I did it I'm amazing I
know I'm amazing amazing
there goes true drop throat Rumble tree
top Trump trouble double toil and
trouble
what is that that's not right don't
dodge slap ouch ouch gosh I'm invisible
slap no I snap I can never slap her
again got it anyway it didn't need the
slapper no why do I shoot away my slaps
murder murder is all I am what they know
is death I want my slaps okay you just
oh man you you guys are ugly you know
what I hate to call a spade a spade but
you guys are oh man you're ugly for
credibly ugly
oh boy yep
I got that slap slap you think you do oh
that was my slap opportunity my slap
eternity where's my slap it - ow why but
got the slap
okay Jesus stop oh oh oh how did I do
that what happened where am I no no no
no no no stop no no why am I so scared
don't know I'm just scared
just turn Elise scared whatever I'm
playing this game okay you seem friendly
oh you got murdered for helping me you
got murdered why why did you get
murdered Oh God
Oh this is awful Oh No
okay all right well all right well
that's so sad why why are they being
horribly murdered just for assisting me
I didn't know what kill me - I got
greedy I'm on normal gun Yee you need to
be a sharp sure to get through these
guys you know what I'm not going normal
gomez oh snap I got the slap oh [ __ ] -
cut the [ __ ]
smell-my slapper
god damn my homing [ __ ] now you take
my smuggler from me
so sad
murder all I know is death that's all I
do I don't even need to kill those guys
do i oh they're not a slapper oh oh oh
oh god you hit me with a slapper
[Music]
finish him off quick a slap oh no I
missed god damn it okay
[Music]
gosh I just can't be Papa Frick slap no
no I think I got that one fine stop
garden that you go away
no no I jumped again why did I jump
forget that ah I'm so twitchy now god
that's the worst thing whenever I get
angry I get twitchy oh god damn it god
damn it I'm fine it's fine it's fine
it's fine
ah got you through this
with my slap tegrity in taxi miss me no
so sad no why a what
how did it kill both that thing and me
without giving me the slap ah no no no
no
oh there we go
I don't know why I care about that so
much
I shouldn't shouldn't let it get to me
[Music]
no not that one don't even know no oh
alright everything's fine
I just gotta like quiet down for a
little bit it's gonna shut my big gob
that's all I gotta do and then wouldn't
you know it magic happens will you just
will you just a why are you not dying
[Music]
excuse me excuse me excuse me
oh now oh now now now we die okay all
right okay you'll be okay
teaching me something hello welcome back
all right jump okay get you at nope okay
all right well that was scary her than
it needed to be definitely why is there
nothing no I I didn't know it'd be this
way why is there Bose no stop in that
way give me another give me another
I hope they can hold me indefinitely
because that's that'd be really nice if
they could do that I don't like this I
hate this I hate this I hate this okay
all right you're dead now I hated that I
could should he use my super but I did
and I didn't -
[Music]
I'll take it
ah okay all right I'm gonna just do one
more boss fight and then that's gonna be
it for it I'm gonna find that it where's
the next boss where's the boss give me a
boss I want to fight a boss so but
before I do the boss I want to let you
guys know Christmas sweaters they're for
sale markiplier calm we're going on tour
again in January and February February
we're going to Europe so check that out
mark blare calm or tor markiplier calm
that is there what are you looking at my
chip hey it's not my fault
I've been busy fighting off those casino
debtors now I gotta save up that my
blade fixed so help me I wish someone
would bust that King dice one alright
okay alright I don't know what that
means but okay hey flowers that's it's
pretty good floral fury why isn't there
a super hard super hard setting that's
what I need alright whatever you say
what's with the jazz hands hahaha that's
what's with the jazz hands I don't like
that come on slap that was supposed to
be a slap up that's just no my slappers
I'm very wha
[Applause]
allergic rhinitis I don't even know what
that means
[Music]
alright
a slapper that's not good wait hand
switch ah what's the pay attention to
where you were jazz handing what is that
what is that what is that why is that
Wow
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa wait whoa
why god damn it I'm not paying attention
[Music]
I know the chaser is weaker but you know
what hey I offset it with my terrible
aim I didn't look I wasn't what fight am
i fighting you're not a slapper
you're not a slow you're a slap oh I
can't get to that slappa
okay all right what
oh no wait no I once then hit me those
[ __ ] why did it hit me it shouldn't
hit me no no no no no I'm not I'm not
stupid
then do Oh God oh oh they come to where
I'm okay all right
not slap up not slap slap ha I've almost
got enough for an ultimate of whatever
this is gonna do no no no I don't know
what this did yeah yeah
ah no that doesn't do ultimate okay I
should switch to maybe I don't have a
super maybe I'm stupid maybe I'm mine am
i stupid the answer is yeah I'm stupid
oh god I hate that okay it's just a nice
calm relaxing whatever we're doing there
I saw you coming
stop jazz handing at me okay I'm gonna
get this guy shoot the seeds no really
shoot the seeds Oh see here I was being
the opposite of smart oh ouch
boom Oh
Oh what is that I don't know if that's
although that's weird
okay Wow all right I hate that that's
awful
oh no no no no oh that's a slap up how
do I slap down look how do we slap down
I don't know
oh I slapped down I did it oh wow I
wasn't watching that's a slap no no
[Music]
where'd your eyes go okay well you're
very dead
okay that's horrifying Oh God my heart
my heart my heart okay
see I ain't so bad I ain't so bad at
this I ain't so bad I just complain a
lot while I'm doing it but I ain't so
bad so thank you everybody so much for
watching that's the end of cuphead for
now I'm gonna do more cut pad obviously
I don't know if I'm doing a livestream
forum or in normal let's play forum but
we shall see remember to go to Margaret
comm to check out the tour remember to
go check out the cool sweatshirts that I
got for Christmas and thanks everybody
so much for watching let me know if you
want to see more of this down the
comments below what's as posted and as
always I'll see you in the next video
bye guys bye babe
by